are indeed with a christopher you
christopher a sharp victory
take us through the emotions of this
game it looked completely wild for us
yeah
i was definitely very confused by most
of the game too
i it was hard to really understand what
was going on or what the evaluation was
how did you assess it at different
moments of this game did you feel like
you got the better out of him out of the
opening
i think i preferred my position a bit
but i expected a much more
normal game where he just castles and i
definitely didn't anticipate the way he
played with queen f6 king e7
let's take a look
queen to f6 bishop to g6
he did have the two bishops he did have
a potential attack via the h file were
you at all concerned at this point or
did you feel secure uh within your
position
i felt relatively safe because i have
this work on h1 kind of stopping his
pawns yes
stopping the move h5
and he played f5
he was really taking the fight to you in
this one pedro
and uh
you retaliated as well queen to f7 queen
to e2
what was the critical moment of the game
in your opinion as we entered these wild
complications
i'm on i'm honestly not really sure what
the most critical moment was but i
thought it was like
a big mistake this whole plan with rick
g8 g6 or cup six
i think maybe he should have just tried
to
bring his knight to e7
and g6 quickly
so he's like the g8
d7 maybe yeah king to d7
and how would you have responded to that
what was uh your plan nightway for or
i'm not exactly sure i was considering a
lot of moves here
like work age five knight a4
were definitely among the top moves i
was considering
so your focus was to
swing between the weakness on h6 and the
weakness potentially of the king on the
queen side yeah and then you guys got to
this position and uh
i will give you a little bit of insight
into the uh assessment of it by the
engines
and we were completely shocked by it did
you see this move at this point what
were your candidate moves that you were
considering
at this after taking on d5 did you
consider anything else but queen f4
i i didn't really think he had anything
good besides queen for
king to d8 apparently was
in fact
equal
oh wow
that's just insane it is
wow
and after queen to f4 it is
you who actually have to start playing
for uh
equality it seems
queen to f4 i believe it was what was it
uh
it's rocket sex games no no no no i
think this is already over because g4 is
a problem
so you have to take on h6
going to f4 and now king to h1 is the
only way for you to make a draw crazy
so what's like the what's the whole
variation after king age one after king
h1 it's uh draw by repetition after rook
f6 0k
wow
yeah wow wow was right that was uh
christopher that was our feelings too
like we wanted to shoot the messenger
it's amazing that christian is still
alive
[Laughter]
but
uh once you played queen takes e6 it was
this boss move knight e4 you you had
calculated actually the game variation
pretty uh well after this we thought
that you were
you you you were pretty certain of a
victory
uh thanks to this knight d2
christopher two and a half out of three
that's a pretty good score how would you
assess your performance so far
very good
very good very good winning when you
have to it definitely seems like you're
on the right track thank you very much
for joining us and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you thank you